bien je suis très heureux
et tous les responsables de notre
mouvement sont heureux je l'exprime par
ma voix
d'accueillir les deux responsables
des deux mouvements
qui avec nous forment l'organisation de
la majorité
dont vous vous souviendrez que le nom
que nous avons choisi qui est à la fois
une dénomination et un mot d'ordre c'est
ensemble
alors quelques mots
extrêmement rapides
sur cette majorité
nous avons toujours considéré
que le mot d'ordre c'était l'Alliance
et l'Alliance
dans la vie
personnelle comme dans la vie politique
ça suppose
estime réciproque
sens de la solidarité
et liberté d'expression
il peut arriver c'est la plupart du
temps le gars que nous soyons
profondément d'accord sur les
orientations
et dans ce cas là
nous l'exprimons et nous allons dans le
même sens
sans qu'il y ait le la moindre nuance
peut arriver
ça arrive aussi
que nous soyons d'accord majoritairement
mais que à l'intérieur de chacun de nos
mouvements
puisse avoir des nuances ça arrive
il y a par exemple des problèmes de
conscience des problèmes éthiques sur
lesquels
chacun s'exprimera
puis peut arriver qui est des nuances
entre mouvements
je pense très important que les Français
mesurent
le devoir de liberté qui est le nôtre
celui de chacune des formations qui sont
là
ce devoir de liberté ne porte pour moi
en rien atteinte à la solidarité
nécessaire
simplement
c'est pour les Français un gage
d'authenticité
si vous êtes pris
contraint
dans une alliance
alors les Français attendent très bien
quand vous vous exprimez que vous
préférez des éléments de langage comme
on dit c'est à dire à peu près le comble
de l'inauthenticité or nous avons choisi
nous
je m'exprimerai demain sur ce sujet
de faire de la démocratie une discipline
et une organisation et une obligation
d'échange de débat
cette liberté si nous réussissons à la
mettre en œuvre est un très important à
tout pour l'avenir
et je dis ça
à Stéphane séjourné à Édouard Philippe
l'un des deux a eu l'occasion de vivre
avec moi assez souvent cette cette
nécessité
et l'autre va évidemment
entrer dans cette dans cette dans ce
sport particulier mais je ne dis pas ça
pour
créer un
climat qui ne serait pas
profondément engagé
je suis sûr
que les majorités précédentes
ont été affaiblis par
l'INS sincérité de leur attitude de
leurs actions
je suis sûr
qu'on a tout à gagner à inventer une
démocratie sereine
et parfaitement sincère
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
très heureux de les accueillir
Édouard Philippe comme vous savez a été
le premier ministre de la France et nous
l'avons soutenu pendant toute cette
période nous avons doué des relations
intéressante
et assez roboratif
repérative ça veut dire qui donne de la
force donc
et Stéphane séjourné le président de
notre groupe au Parlement européen et
donc il a avec chacun d'entre nous les
parlementaires européens et puis les
moins en tant que responsable du parti
démocrateur européen
nous avons des relations qui sont
évidemment très très intéressantes et
qui doivent s'approfondir
il comprend ce que je veux dire je
comprends ce que je veux dire c'est déjà
très bien
[Rires]
et il doit Philippe affirme qu'il a
compris aussi et donc et donc cette mode
aussi et le dit aussi vous voyez les
elle se elle se rebiffe donc
voilà ce que je voulais dire pour
la chaleur de l'accueil que de leur
réservons et la franchise de vos
applaudissements
la parole est à Stéphane séjourné
merci
cher François cher tout ça fait déjà
trois fois que je suis invité à cette
journée de Guidel c'est toujours un
immense plaisir et tu l'as rappelé je
fais aussi un peu partie de la famille
je suis votre président de groupe au
Parlement européen et c'est avec
fierté la table ronde la démontrer tout
à l'heure une grande fierté
de tous les combats politiques que nous
avons gagné depuis cinq ans avec les
parlementaires du MoDem avec les
parlementaires d'horizons avec les
parlementaires de en marche qui forment
cette grande famille je pense que nous
avons changé je le disais l'année
dernière déjà partie de la
manière dont était perçues la classe
politique dans cette institution qui est
le Parlement européen c'est grâce à vous
c'est grâce au parlementaire je voulais
leur rendre hommage et rendre un hommage
appuyé aussi à Mariel qui a beaucoup
œuvré
à développer
[Applaudissements]
votre influence notre influence au
Parlement européen
dans cette dernière dans ces dernières
années je vais peut-être revenir je
serai pas long mais peut-être sur la
table ronde d'avant François pour
expliquer aussi
nos relations politiques après puisque
il y a une très grande cohérence
j'étais
hier en Italie pour conclure les
meetings politiques de nos
de nos parties frères au niveau européen
qui se battent aujourd'hui pour éviter
l'arrivée du populisme aux portes de
l'Europe toujours l'occasion de dire que
les élections nationales sont des
élections européennes elles sont des
élections européennes parce que elles
détermine aussi au Conseil de l'Europe
choisi un premier ministre détermine
aussi le devenir des citoyens européens
de tous les États membres et ça prend
d'autant plus d'importance aujourd'hui
quand on a vécu la première partie de
ces années 2020
et cette année 2020 ont quand même
bouleversé un certain nombre de choses
qui aujourd'hui rendent encore plus
important et j'y vais y revenir l'unité
le rassemblement ensemble qui est pas un
mauvais que nous avons à construire et
nous avons encore à faire vivre pendant
ces 5 prochaines années
je le dis parce que l'adversaire de
notre famille politique au sens large de
notre rassemblement de notre coalition
restera malheureusement encore dans les
prochaines années on le voit se
développer un peu partout en Europe les
extrémistes l'extrême droite notamment
et on l'a bien vu que ces crises ont
apporté beaucoup de bien le tableau rond
de la démontrer les pattes géants qu'on
a fait sur la construction européenne
les pâtes géants qu'on a fait sur la
construction y compris de l'Europe de la
défense les pas de géants qu'on a fait y
compris dans la tête des Européens quand
les Européens sont venus protéger les
populations mais mine de rien les
derniers prochaines crises
l'augmentation du de l'énergie
l'inflation va aussi drainer un certain
nombre de phénomènes bien connus en
Europe l'inflation
le jeu des populistes tout ça ce sera
évidemment un des grands enjeux de 2024
un des grands enjeux sur lequel moi je
veux qu'on puisse travailler avec une
force importante on est en train de
constituer en Europe un pôle des
progressistes des démocrates des
libéraux qui doit faire face et je fais
le parallèle parce que la presse
italienne m'interrogeait sur la
situation française
les amis de part deux fois en 2017 et en
2022 nous avons été le barrage aux
extrémistes ne vous laissez pas mettre
dans les cordes par d'ailleurs nos
opposants qui souvent nous accusent de
soi les faire monter quand les dénonce
ou soit de les mettre en valeur quand on
les combats mais par deux fois en 2017
et en 2022 notre coalition de fait a
fait barrage éventuellement à l'arrivée
des extrémistes en France et notamment
du Front national du rassemblement
national et de l'ensemble des des
responsables politiques qui qui drainent
cette cette idéologie donc il faut qu'on
soit fier de ça fier de ça parce que je
me rappelle du contexte et Edouard
Philippe et François Baillot s'en
rappellent également du conseil de 2017
heureusement que nous avions cette
famille politique le MoDem qui est venu
avec nous qui a constitué une coalition
et quand on voit après quand c'est
prolongé c'est constitué cette élection
de 2017 avec les affaires à droite
l'incapacité de la gauche de se
rassembler
quel aurait été le deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle en 2017
est-ce que les Français n'auraient pas
eu à faire aux extrêmes ou aux extrêmes
donc je voudrais remettre
un discours offensif sur cette question
là on est depuis 2017 et on a fait le
choix de la construction notamment de
pouvoir gouverner ensemble pendant cinq
ans le barrage au rassemblement national
et aux extrémistes dans ce pays il faut
en avoir conscience et soyez fiers aussi
de la construction politique qu'on a eu
à ce moment là et qu'on doit continuer à
avoir notamment au niveau européen je
reviens sur les cinq dernières années on
a gouverné pendant 5 ans ensemble on a
affronté les crises on a également su
protéger le pays la pandémie des
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
avec une certaine réussite collective on
a également réussi à être assemblé pour
gouverner et pour gagner des élections
je pense aux élections présidentielles
mais aussi aux élections européennes
avec une majorité aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale
peut parfois avoir une forme de
d'approche je partage là dessus François
paillerou ou peut faire les loges de la
différence tout en faisant l'éloge de
l'unité et je pense que c'est ce que
nous a aussi c'est mutuellement entre
tenu mutuellement créer une culture
politique commune sur sur ces questions
là et je pense que c'est possible et
depuis 5 ans nous le vivons comme ça et
je pense qu'on a réussi en tout cas dans
cette dans cette dynamique à pouvoir le
démontrer
à l'inverse d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de la
nupesse qui était qu'une alliance
électorale peut-être de circonscription
et de circonstances mais on voit bien
les difficultés aujourd'hui de faire
cette alliance pour gouverner les
oppositions se sont alliés pour
s'opposer on a décidé de s'allier pour
gouverner le pays ce qui est déjà une
chose beaucoup plus compliquée quand on
sait les mécanismes qui nous amènent aux
responsabilités donc là dessus aussi
c'est un deuxième élément de fierté je
pense de cette organisation collective
et puis le MoDem a été aussi je le dis
François vous avez été
et je le dis aussi
à Guidel d'autant plus de manière
d'autant plus convaincue vous avez
apporté des choses à cette majorité je
pense notamment cette humanisme et tout
ce qui traverse aujourd'hui les
politiques publiques qu'on peut nous
aussi concevoir d'abord vous le savez
tu es le diplômé de l'être classique qui
qui sait ce que c'est l'humanisme
l'émancipation de l'homme nous aussi
nous y croyons vous avez apporté aussi
cette dimension l'épanouissement
individuel la question notamment de
l'héritage que nous pouvons avoir dans
notre vie politique autour de cette
belle majorité vous avez participé en
tout cas à construire
cette doctrine et ses valeurs que nous
avons aujourd'hui tous partagé et que je
partage aussi dans Renaissance quand on
regarde l'ensemble des militants cette
dimension humaniste est également
présente et c'est aussi
grâce à vous je pense notamment à
l'Europe on en a parlé longuement mais
vous avez pas été des Européens et on
peut intermittent dans la période ce
parti est cohérent cette organisation et
ce mouvement est cohérent vous avez su
déjà des 2017 je me rappelle très bien
ici à Guidel en parlant
de l'Europe de la défense peut-être même
en premier Jean-Yves Le Drian le disait
que on avait des difficultés à pouvoir
convaincre nos partenaires mais déjà à
l'époque cette question là était posée
dès 2017 dans un des partis politiques
français qui a progressé et donc vous
avez aussi participé à ça et puis enfin
peut-être la question de proportionnelle
j'étais à peu près sûr de mon coup
question de proportionnelle j'ai la j'ai
la conviction il faudra interroger
d'ailleurs les militants de Renaissance
on aura également ce débat entre nous
mais j'ai la conviction que la
composition de l'Assemblée nationale
montre que les Français aspirent à une
meilleure représentativité des forces
politiques au Parlement ils nous l'ont
montré par les élections faut maintenant
passer de peut-être la proportionnelle
de fait imposer en quelque sorte à la
proportionnelle choisie
organisée par nos institutions et donc
ça sera un débat qu'on aura entre
formation politique mais c'est un débat
que je veux mener avec aussi
l'intelligence de votre approche qui est
longue sur le terrain et puis votre
conviction sur ces sujets là voilà il y
aura
il y aura évidemment des choix à faire
dans les dans les prochains mois et dans
les prochaines semaines sur les
politiques publiques évidemment
on aura peut-être je le disais des
approches différentes mais nous pourrons
toujours faire l'éloge de l'unité c'est
le cas sur la réforme des retraites où
je pense que sincèrement le comme tu le
dis souvent François également c'est un
projet de société et pas un choix
budgétaire je partage aussi cette
conviction on connaît tous le point
d'atterrissage on a le droit d'avoir des
discussions de comment on y va ça n'a me
gêne pas et c'est débats sont plutôt
sains dans une majorité qui peut vivre
c'est une question de sincérité mais
c'est aussi une question de vie
collectif si on veut que ce cela dure et
dans tout collectif si on veut que ça
dure il faut pouvoir faire vivre ce
collectif avec ses différences et ses
sensibilités ces sensibilités
différentes et j'en serais aussi le
garant à ma place la mienne j'ai
beaucoup travaillé
avec les parlementaires européens on est
maintenant 103 parlementaires de 25
nationalités différentes de 40 partis
politiques différentes partout en Europe
avec évidemment
une
géographies différentes des intérêts
différents des fois mais ça nous empêche
pas de voter à 95% la même chose dans
l'hémicycle après avoir fait des débats
après avoir construit des compromis
après avoir organisé nos débats internes
qui sont pas des prises de gueule entre
les uns les autres mais des débats
constructifs je pense qu'on peut y
arriver pendant ces cinq dernières
années tout simplement parce que les
Français nous regardent et que nous
sommes en responsabilité
et les Français peuvent être parfois
très durs avec les gens qui sont en
responsabilité et nous le devons aussi
cette exigence de débat mutuel je
regarde notamment le PS qui a
dissolu un peu près tout ce qui était de
ces valeurs et de ses idées dans le
mélange jaunisse la droite qui ferait de
plus en plus dont les digues sont en
train de se s'effondrer avec l'extrême
droite alors on est le pôle de stabilité
de ce pays il faut l'assumer avec des
responsabilités derrière je pense on est
devenu les seules parties de
gouvernement aujourd'hui quand on écoute
les responsables politiques dans les
médias et dans leurs interventions
publiques alors c'est avec une immense
responsabilité que nous assumons
l'humilité dans l'unité et aujourd'hui
et demain et après-demain en tout cas je
l'espère merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Édouard Philippe
Mesdames et Messieurs chers amis merci
cher François de m'avoir
invité à Guidel et merci de m'avoir
proposé de prendre la parole je suis
sensible je voudrais
je voudrais
c'est un remerciement sincère je
voudrais je voudrais saluer avant de
commencer à vous parler mesdames et
messieurs je voudrais saluer
Marc et Geneviève que je suis heureux de
retrouver ici après avoir
souffert parfois avec mais aussi
beaucoup riz avec eux dans d'autres
moments
et en tout cas après avoir pu pendant
trois ans compter sur leur loyauté sur
leur amitié je crois et sur leur
efficacité donc vraiment je les salue
avec beaucoup d'amitié
je suis je suis très heureux aussi de
retrouver Jean-Yves
et heureux et impatient j'arrive
car tu as tu as laissé entrevoir
discrètement c'est vrai mais néanmoins
explicitement que tu avais des talents
au platine
et je crois comprendre que
l'organisation d'événement laisse une
place importante à la dimension festive
ce soir
il faudra donc que tu nous montres que
les Bretons savent tenir leurs promesses
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais rassurer Jean-Paul Mattei
qui m'a vu saisir mon
iPad la semaine dernière il m'a vu à
Fontainebleau et quand j'ai saisi mon
iPad j'ai ensuite parlé pendant une
heure et demie donc il se dit merde ça
va être enfin ils se disent zut il va y
avoir droit encore pendant une heure et
demie t'inquiète pas ça va être plus
court enfin je voudrais essayer de le le
dernier que je voudrais remercier très
très sincèrement dans votre assemblée
saloué saluer Jean-Louis bourlange car
grâce à lui nous savons désormais nous
avons participé à une réunion politique
ensemble dans laquelle il a été dit que
Jean-Pierre Chevènement éloquence était
pareil
je crois mesdames et messieurs
que personne ici
[Applaudissements]
que personne au sein de l'OTAN
et que certainement pas Jean-Pierre
Chevènement aurait pu imaginer une
pareille correspondance
je suis aussi de retrouver Stéphane je
le salue avec amitié et je vais
d'ailleurs revenir sur un certain nombre
de choses qui a dit parce que je les
partage tout à fait complètement en tout
cas je suis heureux d'être à Guidel vous
vous avez l'habitude de guider le ça
fait 10 ans je crois que que vous venez
à Guidel moi c'est la deuxième fois
alors la première fois c'était un
précédent la deuxième fois c'est le
début d'un usage
et je me réjouis et je me réjouis et
donc vivement la vivement la prochaine
je rappelle à ceux qui l'ignoreraient
encore ce que j'ai appris c'est pour ça
que je le dis avec beaucoup de
certitudes il y a quelques heures que la
devise de Guidel c'était
loyal et fidèle toujours
c'est fait exprès
bien sûr loyal et fidèle toujours donc
très bien soyons loyaux et fidèle
toujours en général et à Guidel en
particulier je suis venu au fond pour
vous dire deux choses je voudrais dire
très simplement sans très simplement
la première et ça rejoint assez
largement ce qu'a dit Stéphane ça
rejoint aussi assez largement ce qu'a
dit François ce qui veut dire que comme
nous nous sommes pas concertés
ça veut dire que nous avons besoin de le
dire et que nous le croyons tous les
trois très sincèrement
l'esprit qui a présidé à la construction
de la majorité présidentielle doit
prévaloir quand je dis de l'esprit qui a
contribué à la
présidé à la construction de la majorité
présidentielle si cette idée cette idée
qui est
apparu progressivement comme toutes les
grandes idées elles se sont parfois
heurtés à la réalité mais l'idée que
nous allions construire une majorité
présidentielle sur le fondement de trois
blocs des blocs d'importance différentes
des blocs dont l'histoire était
différente dont le corpus idéologique
était différent dont l'âge de la
formation politique était différent
trois blocs
différents donc qui avait vocation
à s'entendre à se comprendre à se faire
confiance
ça n'est pas rien parce que dans la vie
politique française et dans l'histoire
de la constitution des majorités
on n'a rien inventé des coalitions des
regroupements il en a existé dans le
passé et probablement en existera-t-il à
l'avenir mais l'idée
de ne pas se cantonner à un bloc et bien
de reconnaître dans une majorité qui
était marquée par l'idée du dépassement
par l'idée que il ne fallait pas rester
assigner à son identité politique
d'origine même si on pouvait la
respecter l'idée de constituer un bloc
au pardon un ensemble c'est le cas de le
dire en trois blocs
et l'idée ça a été je pense qu'on peut
aller encore un peu plus loin dans cette
idée ça a été de constituer un système
dans lequel chaque bloc
est libre
libre et autonome
mais chaque bloc est relié par un lien
qui n'est pas simplement un engagement
verbal pas simplement une déclaration
politique mais des liens structurels qui
ne sont pas négligeables nous avons au
moment des élections législatives et ça
n'est pas rien présenter des candidats
sous une candidature commune
sous une candidature commune et l'effet
de cette candidature c'était que
lorsqu'il se déclarait en préfecture
comme ici il y a des gens qui savent à
peu près ce que c'est qu'une élection je
peux développer ce point là lorsqu'il se
déclarait en préfecture il se déclarait
sous le nom ensemble ça veut dire que
tout à fait conscient de leur
appartenance à une formation politique
il ils affirmaient devant les Français
en toute transparence que leur formation
politique avait vocation appartenir à un
ensemble qui s'assumait comme tel pour
la répartition des financements pour les
déclarations en préfecture pour la
répartition des investitures c'est un
travail d'une grande intensité
et à mon avis tu as un très grand
intérêt qui a été réalisé par les trois
composantes de ce mouvement ensemble et
je voudrais puisque nous sommes en
Bretagne et puisque nous sommes à Guidel
dire que ce moment de travail très
intense avec François avec Richard
Ferrand autre breton
je dis autre breton pas parce que je
suis breton personnellement je suis
normand c'est assez différent je dis
autre breton en regardant Jean-Yves
autre breton que je salue avec beaucoup
d'amitié avec la participation amicale
mais ferme de Marc feno
un travail à la fois passionnant
et sur lequel je crois nous pouvons
construire beaucoup
ça c'est ce que je voulais dire
et pour que cet ensemble
cette structuration de trois blocs je me
méfie parce que François est en train de
prendre des notes
pour que ça marche
pour que ça marche il faut il faut
évidemment que nous tenions les
engagements que nous avons pris très
bien il faut que nous tenions les
engagements que nous avons pris il faut
que nous respections nos partenaires qui
sur l'essentiel je rejoins assez
naturellement François et Stéphane sont
d'accord mais qui ont parfois des
différences de vue soit en interne soit
globalement avec leur partenaire il faut
qu'il y a une relation qui soit une
relation de respect et de confiance
et c'est facile de s'engager
et c'est difficile d'avoir la discipline
collective
de tenir cet engagement et donc je veux
dire deux choses sur ce point d'abord
que je ferai tout ce qui est en mon
possible exactement comme Stéphane la
déclaré exactement comme François le
fait pour tenir cette discipline cet
engagement que nous avons pris et je
voudrais saluer les efforts et la
qualité du travail effectué par la
première ministre Elisabeth borne qui
est extrêmement attentive à cette
discussion extrêmement attentive à la
qualité de nos échanges
et comme je sais que c'est pas facile
ben je la remercie encore plus
je vous assure
l'objectif l'objectif c'est évidemment
pas simplement de se faire plaisir en
constituant un ensemble à trois
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir permettre la
mise en place de quelque chose
ensemble qui de notre point de vue avait
vocation à la fois élargir le bloc
central et la majorité présidentielle et
d'une façon alors raciner et donc ce qui
est à l'oeuvre dans cet ensemble ça
n'est pas simplement une tactique
électorale de 2022 à mon sens ça n'est
pas non plus une forme de stabilisation
d'une majorité qui est apparue et devenu
une majorité relative c'est
véritablement je crois le support
durable du rassemblement futur de tous
les éléments du bloc central qui est
indispensable si nous voulons à la fois
conserver la la maîtrise des affaires
publiques et si nous voulons continuer à
faire avancer notre pays et donc je me
félicite et je voudrais le dire du
travail avec avec François intéressantes
a-t-il dit pour qualifier nos relations
et ça c'est juste ça c'est juste
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
ça n'était pas forcément acquis
faut reconnaître ça n'était pas
forcément acquis l'idée que ça puisse se
passer bien nous nous sommes assez
différents avec François nous avons au
moment des élections légatives fait deux
concerts une campagne électorale dans la
belle ville petite et belle ville de
tonnerre dans l'Yonne Bourgogne
et l'ordre de ce de cette de ce meeting
qui était un assez beau meeting parce
qu'on était dans une très belle enfin
bon bref
lors de ce lors de ce meeting je me
souviens avoir dit et je pourrais le
dire dans les mêmes termes aujourd'hui
que il y avait quand même beaucoup de
différences entre nous
françois est un littéraire je suis un
juriste et il est il est ne l'ignore
Béarnais je suis moi-même normand
et ce sont deux caractères différents
il est montagnard je suis plutôt porté
vers la mer
il est et il a raison de l'être fier
d'être au fond le dépositaire et
l'incarnation la plus éminente du la
famille centriste qui puisse ses racines
dans l'histoire politique de la France
et je suis pour ma part plus sensible
sans être complètement insensible à la
famille centriste car je suis dormant
erwanais je suis d'abord à vrai ça c'est
compliqué
mais moi-même plutôt sensible à la
droite
du libéralisme à la française et à la
mystique gaulliste parce que on se
refait pas et donc évidemment ces
petites différences qui sont jamais
rédhibitoires heureusement mais elle
compte à ça vous ajoutez quelque chose
stratégique différent dans la vie
politique dans les 20 dernières années
et bien vous avez tout ce qu'il faut
pour que ce soit plus compliqué
mais
et au fond c'est presque plus important
vous avez aussi
un certain sens de la litote
nous avons découvert avec François que
lui qui parle couramment le Béarnais moi
qui parle couramment le Normand les deux
langues avaient de fortes
correspondances lorsqu'il s'agit de la
litote
et puis encore plus sérieux parce que je
m'en voudrais de rester que sur un
registre léger je crois que nous
partageons sur beaucoup de points sur de
très nombreux points des convergences
d'analyses et une volonté de ne rien
lâcher pour que on essaie de s'en sortir
qu'on essaie d'avancer et qu'on essaie
d'être à la hauteur des enjeux et ça ça
compte ça compte même beaucoup et ça
compte même de plus en plus et donc en
dépit de tout ça
ou grâce à tout ça je crois pouvoir dire
avec François je crois aussi pouvoir le
dire avec Stéphane je crois surtout
pouvoir le dire avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires qui composent l'ensemble
des trois groupes nous avons le substrat
commun qui nous permet d'avancer à la
condition je le redis que
nous fassions prévaloir toujours
l'esprit qui a présidé à la construction
de la majorité présidentielle c'est la
première chose que je veux dire la
deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que
c'est très très bien de conserver cet
esprit c'est d'autant plus nécessaire
que nous allons quand même être
confrontés à des trucs assez bizarres
et quand je dis bizarre je veux dire
rude
je veux dire difficile c'est très facile
en ce moment d'avoir un discours
pessimiste parce que toute la raison
nous y conduit pour avoir un discours
optimiste il faut presque faire appel à
des catégories intellectuelles qui sont
moins la raison que la foi
ça compte je vais pas dire le contraire
ici
en Bretagne mais c'est presque de cette
nature là nous allons faire face à des
choses qui sont difficiles François l'a
dit avec beaucoup de clarté il y a
quelques semaines dans un dans un long
article dans une longue interview qui a
qui s'est vu et qui a fait à juste titre
parler et réagir j'avais moi-même il y a
quelques mois ou quelques années parler
de tempête que je voyais venir Jean-Yves
a dit tout à l'heure avec beaucoup de
clarté tous les bouleversements et les
désordres du monde qu'il lisaient dans
les évolutions actuelles de notre
société de notre planète
nous sommes en face d'un
d'une transformation liée à des facteurs
extrêmement divers au bouleversement
géopolitique alors il y a la foi la
surpuissance chinoise il y a à la fois
le désordre russe en Ukraine il y a
l'avènement de plus en plus net de plus
en plus puissant et de plus en plus
dangereux me semble-t-il d'idées selon
lesquelles les démocraties occidentales
notre régime démocratique celui auquel
nous sommes attachés et peut-être
d'ailleurs pas suffisamment parce que ça
fait tellement longtemps qu'il est là
qu'on a l'impression qu'il sera toujours
là que notre régime démocratique nos
régimes démocratiques ne sont plus les
mieux placés pour garantir à la fois la
prospérité du monde et la stabilité du
monde mais pendant très longtemps on a
pensé ça on a pensé que de toute
évidence les régimes qui garantissaient
cette stabilité et cette prospérité avec
en plus la liberté c'était des régimes
démocratiques et qu'est-ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui à la fois en termes
de prospérité économique à la fois en
termes de puissance militaire et à la
fois même parfois en termes de capacité
à répondre aux enjeux de la planète
l'idée selon laquelle au fond nos
démocraties serait trop faible trop
inefficace pour apporter des réponses
crédibles au sujet que nous devons
régler il y a là un changement
intellectuel une menace intellect je le
partage pas du tout cet avis je voudrais
qu'on soit très clair entre nous
mais cette idée là ce poison là cette
remise en cause là elles sont
extrêmement dangereuses et elles sont
extrêmement puissantes bouleversement
géopolitique ensuite d'abord
urgence climatique
urgence climatique d'ailleurs c'est je
constate qu'au fur et à mesure
quel apparaît nous parlons de moins en
moins de développement durable et de
plus en plus d'urgence climatiques je
pense que dans l'évolution de la
sémantique il n'y a pas qu'un hasard il
y a une signification profonde c'est de
moins en moins la question du
développement durable qui se pose ou qui
nous occupent et de plus en plus la
question de l'urgence climatique et de
notre capacité à y apporter une réponse
crédible pas simplement une réponse mais
une réponse crédible qui s'oppose vous
l'avez tous vu pendant les campagnes et
si vous ne le voyez pas pendant les
campagnes vous le voyez forcément soit
pendant les déjeuners ou les dîners de
famille soit à chaque fois que vous
allez dans une université ou dans une
école et que vous vous prêtez au jeu de
la discussion cette urgence climatique
elle est le sujet numéro un et c'est pas
une mode le sujet numéro un des
générations un peu plus jeunes que moi
donc que nous
et c'est un énorme sujet et c'est un
énorme sujet qui va parfois jusqu'à
remettre en cause
l'idée de croissance l'idée de progrès
l'idée de liberté politique
l'idée de liberté individuelle
la question de savoir
lorsque vous écoutez des des gens qui ne
sont pas forcément des extrémistes
politiques mais qui vous disent au fond
l'état de la planète aujourd'hui impose
que nous nous posions la question qui
est très politique de savoir ce qui est
nécessaire et ce qui est superflu pour
nous concentrer sur le nécessaire et
pour abandonner le superflu mais
mesdames et messieurs politiquesment
déterminé ce qui est superflu c'est
redoutablement complexe je ne suis même
pas sûr que ce soit une bonne idée vous
voyez bien les affres politiques dans
lesquels nous allons être plongés pour
faire face à cette urgence climatique
qui est indispensable
c'est assez facile une fois qu'on a
saisi l'ampleur du vertige d'être un peu
pessimiste et puis il y a des effets
puissants sur nos vies de phénomènes
dont on parle trop peu je voudrais citer
deux très rapides parce qu'ils doivent
nous faire réfléchir premier phénomène
dont nous parlons vraiment très peu au
fond mais que nous vivons tous les jours
l'impact des révolutions technologiques
et des évolutions technologiques sur nos
vies sur la notion de liberté sur la
façon dont nous nous projetons à
l'avenir ses propres mots vertigineux
toutes les semaines tous les mois on
fait des découvertes scientifiques
ou des applications nouvelles
technologiques qui nous font passer
insensiblement des frontières que nous
pensions relativement posées peut-être
pas totalement ferme parce que quand
même mais relativement posé en matière
de biotechnologie et le Parlement sans
fait les cours heureusement et légifère
et heureusement sur les questions de
bioéthique mais en général illégifère
avec un peu de retard et le rythme
auquel ces évolutions se propagent et se
développent et proprement vertigineux
qu'est-ce que c'est la liberté dans un
monde où l'hyper connectivité et l'hyper
traçabilité deviennent la norme et
accessible à tout le monde qu'est-ce que
c'est la démocratie dans un monde où au
fond les lieux communs de débat sont
totalement émiettés
et où les communautés n'ont pas par
l'effet d'un choix mais par l'effet d'un
algorithme finissent par se renforcer
entre elles-mêmes la démocratie par
nature impose que nous sortions de
nous-mêmes et que nous discutions et que
nous discute que nous discutions avec
des gens qui ne sont pas d'accord
aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux il
faut bien les reconnaître nous sommes
dirigés vers des gens qui pensent comme
nous et le renforcement des gens qui
pensent comme nous nous donnent le
sentiment on n'est pas tout seul et donc
on a raison
et il y a une perversion terrible du
débat public terrible et elle n'est pas
la seule mais vous voyez bien que la
menace que cela fait peser sur le débat
public la menace que ça fait peser sur
nos démocraties est absolument
considérable j'en arrête avec les
révolutions technologiques j'en viens à
un deuxième phénomène le phénomène
démographique je passe sur l'explosion
démographique à l'échelle de la planète
je dis juste juste cette chose dans le
quinquennat qui vient c'est pas dans 20
ans dans les 5 ans qui viennent
le nombre d'écoliers de collégiens et de
lycéens mais en vérité d'abord
d'écoliers ça va pas tellement se voir
au niveau du lycée ça va surtout au
niveau des écoles va baisser de 500 000
500000 bon il y a beaucoup d'écoliers en
France mais enfin 500 000 ça va se voir
500 000 ça n'est pas rien 500 000 c'est
une une
interrogation collective considérable
sur le monde de demain
personne n'en parle on a tous et ici
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs un
attachement à la politique familiale non
mais tu as vu je me suis rattrapé quand
même
ici plus qu'ailleurs un attachement à la
politique familiale mais la vérité vraie
c'est que dans le débat public la
question de savoir le monde que nous la
France que nous nous préparons à 20 ans
alors que nous sommes dans une
génération très creuse
que nous devrons payer les retraites
aussi dans 20 ans
ma semble presque déconnecté de la
réalité donc quand on met tout à bout et
encore j'ai beaucoup de choses que j'ai
pas évoqué on a le droit d'être un peu
inquiet
et on a d'autant plus le droit d'être
traqué qu'on affronte ces sujets dans
une situation de relatif fragilité
relative fragilité alors heureusement
elle n'est pas général cette fragilité
d'abord parce que la France et la France
qu'elle a de la ressource quelle est la
depuis longtemps qu'elle a des talents
extraordinaires qu'elle a et d'une
certaine façon nous l'avons vu mais
enfin elle était là bien avant nous elle
sera bien après nous et elle a des
caractéristiques qui font que elle a de
la ressource la France et puis aussi
parce que Stéphane eu raison de le
souligner
on n'est pas resté les deux pieds dans
le même sabot dans les cinq dernières
années et un certain nombre d'actions
qui ont été mises en œuvre lors du
dernier quinquennat il y a d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d'actions qui ont été mis
en oeuvre avant le dernier quinquennat
qui était bien aussi il y en a d'autres
qui étaient moins bien enfin on n'est
pas dans une dans une dichotomie ou nous
très bien les autres très mal c'est pas
vrai c'est pas ça la démocratie
on a quand même réussi à renforcer un
certain nombre de domaines bon je dis
l'apprentissage parce que c'est
probablement ce qui me réjouit le plus
enfin il y en a beaucoup d'autres que je
pourrais citer mais enfin une fois qu'on
s'a dit ça pour se rassurer on est quand
même face à des grandes fragilités la
crise les crispations sociales
nous abordons des crises redoutables
avec un niveau de crispation sociale qui
est quand même extrêmement élevé le
malaise démocratique qui réel dans la
qualité du débat public dans le lien que
nos concitoyens tissent avec leur
représentants dans l'espoir qu'ils ont
que leur représentants trouvent des
solutions et la capacité d'ailleurs à
les accepter bref à bien des égards le
malaise démocratique il est perceptible
et il est évidemment extrêmement
inquiétant
dans une certaine forme aussi de
défiance de ce que nous sommes
j'ai toujours pris avec beaucoup de
distance les gens qui vous expliquer que
la France ontologiquement c'était mieux
que tout le monde que d'ailleurs les
Français étaient ontologiquement plus
intelligents que tous les autres et que
circuler il y a rien à voir et qu'on
avait le meilleur modèle pour tout ça
n'est pas vrai
mais il y a en France très fortement et
vous le voyez très bien une forme de
défiance de ce que nous sommes les
absences de de reconnaissance d'absence
de confiance d'absence de de plaisir de
joie et de fierté d'être ce que nous
sommes et quand je dis ça j'appelle pas
tout le monde à être naïvement
extrêmement fier mais je constate le
pessimisme
récurrent
les Allemands ont un mot pour ça
l'espèce de honte de soi dans laquelle
parfois parfois nous nous complaisons
qui est d'ailleurs la contrepartie d'une
fierté qui me semble souvent excessive
et donc il est il est absolument
indispensable d'avoir conscience que
notre tissu national notre nation bien
loin d'être soudée autour d'un projet
elle est inquiète de ce qu'elle est de
ce qu'elle est devenue
le fondement je prends deux sujets très
vite des choses qui apparaissent comme
des fondements de ce que notre pays
l'école
la sécurité sociale
l'école depuis longtemps la sécurité
sociale depuis 45 enfin vous avez là
deux fondements l'idée de dire que nous
nous sommes organisés pour avoir une
puissance publique l'État pour l'État
euh non l'État pour l'école et
l'organisation sociale pour la sécurité
sociale qui sont capables de répondre à
des besoins essentiels la santé d'un
côté l'école de l'autre et ben c'est
deux ils sont tous les deux en crise
en crise profonde
les gens les regardent en se disant il
ne fonctionne plus comme ils devraient
je n'y trouve plus mon compte
l'éducation et tout ce qu'elle devrait
amener à mes enfants n'est plus garanti
dans des conditions qui me paraissent
raisonnables
et beaucoup de nos concitoyens pensa et
l'accès aux soins et la qualité du son à
la qualité du son n'est pas en cause
en général n'est pas du tout en cause
mais l'accès aux soins est
redoutablement complexe et dans le genre
petit élément venant dissoudre la
confiance et éroder la force du tissu
national il n'y a pas mieux
donc vous avez ces deux piliers en crise
et vous avez cette défiance qui se qui
se poursuit si vous ajoutez à ça une
addiction à la dépense publique qui nous
a conduit à avoir des dettes qui sont
importantes là aussi telles que François
connaît par cœur et qu'il développe
depuis longtemps que je partage avec lui
et bien nous attaquons une période
difficile avec des fragilités elle ne
condamnant rien notre pays elle ne nous
condamne rien mais ne pas les voir
serait dangereux ne pas les voir serait
même probablement irresponsable je
prends un petit mot mais je dirais très
vite sur les retraites pas du tout pour
dire ce qu'il faut faire le débat lieu
j'ai pas envie de rajouter une petite
phrase je vais simplement vous dire ça
ça fait la première fois que j'ai
entendu parler de la question des
retraites j'étais en seconde et c'était
il y a longtemps croyez-moi
malheureusement c'était en seconde et
c'était mon professeur d'économie qui
était au tableau
il peut vous dire qu'il y avait pas
d'informatique il était au tableau il
nous a fait des courbes et nous a dit
voyez système de retraite un jour il va
y avoir un problème parce que de plus en
plus c'est la démographie
donc il va falloir régler le problème
c'était presque simple sur son tableau
nous sommes un pays où depuis autant que
je m'en souvienne 35 ans
37 même si je compte
où nous savons qu'il y a un problème
où nous essayons de le régler ou parfois
nous apportons des pierres dans
l'édifice et d'une certaine façon tant
mieux mais où ce problème est devenu
constitutif de la crise de nerfs
national de notre incapacité à appuyer
nos décisions sur des chiffres et avoir
un débat rationnel et je le dis avec
beaucoup d'humilité parce que j'ai
beaucoup cotisé sur le sujet
pas pour le système de retraite aussi
mais mais sur le sujet donc je dis avec
beaucoup d'humilité je dis pas du tout
que moi je sais ce qu'il faut faire et
que les autres ils savent pas c'est pas
du tout ça que je veux dire ce que je
veux dire c'est que collectivement notre
pays depuis 35 ans 35 ans est empêtré
dans un sujet dont je me permets
d'observer qu'il a toujours été réglé
dans tous les pays comparables de la
même façon ce qui devrait quand même
nous laisser penser que
vous voyez il doit y avoir des solutions
on tergiverse on se perd on hésite on
critique et on a le droit on manifeste
on a le droit aussi et finalement on ne
règle pas un problème d'une certaine
façon il ne faut pas s'étonner
que les générations les plus jeunes nous
disent écoutez l'urgence climatique
c'est vraiment compliqué à résoudre et
vous y arrivez pas ça c'est plus simple
les gens ils ont déjà réglé et vous y
arrivez pas non plus donc l'urgence
climatique vous n'y arriverez pas donc
il y a un problème vraiment de capacité
à faire avancer les choses et les
retraites
s'inscrivent dans ce sujet François a
dit très clairement et c'est
parfaitement respectable et en plus
c'est fondé sur une analyse qui est
souvent juste sa position moi j'ai dit
avec le même souci que François
d'arriver à la réforme
et la même lecture des difficultés qu'il
a pointé que quoi qu'il arrive
nous soutiendrions
fermement le gouvernement
mais décidons vite ne laissons pas
dérivés ce sujet cette hésitation décide
et faisons en sorte que soit on bouge
rapidement soit on bouge un peu moins
rapidement mais disons comment nous
allons faire nous n'avons pas besoin de
rajouter des hésitations à un sujet qui
est déjà assez compliqué me semble-t-il
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire et
voilà les sujets que on pourrait
développer sur l'école sur la justice
sur la justice
sur la santé mais je serais trop long si
je continue alors je voudrais terminer
par ceci qui intéresse Stéphane car la
semaine dernière j'étais au Congrès qui
a qui a permis la naissance de
renaissance
on peut le dire comme ça et je voudrais
dire combien je trouve que c'est un nom
extraordinaire
Renaissance la Renaissance dans la dans
notre
imaginaire dans notre histoire dans
notre culture la Renaissance est très
fortement associée à l'humanisme
Stéphane a eu raison de le dire
et l'humanisme dans le monde dans lequel
nous vivons n'est pas moins important
que dans le monde dans lequel cette
valeur est née
il y a quelque chose qui est m'a
toujours paru
non je devrais pas dire ça parce que si
je le dis ça va être mal interprété
non je vais pas le dire
c'est sur ce jeu en fait que j'ai
toujours été un peu agacé qu'on pense
que la Renaissance n'était que
l'humanisme a eu des trucs terribles
pendant la Renaissance mais terrible et
que le moyen-âge aurait été par
définition la période la plus sombre de
notre histoire alors qu'il y a des trucs
glorieux pendant bref une fois qu'on a
dit ça et j'enlève toutes les analogies
que vous pourriez entendre je reviens à
cette idée que la Renaissance me paraît
glorieuse pas simplement pour
l'humanisme mais parce que elle est un
moment et elle est un moment qui nous
dit beaucoup de choses sur notre
situation aujourd'hui ou au fond deux
idées vont s'imposer je crois
et se parler l'idée de fondation
et l'idée de réconciliation comme je
savais que j'allais venir ici j'ai lu
récemment un bon livre que je vous
recommande qui est une biographie d'un
roi qui est très très lié à une ville du
Béarn
Henri IV le roi libre dit l'auteur qui
dédit le livre aux amoureux de la
réconciliation bon et ben si on regarde
les deux les deux grandes figures de la
Renaissance française
c'est François 1er Henri IV et au fond
qui ont chacun leur pardon
surtout François 1er d'ailleurs
non mais
[Applaudissements]
François 1er il a dit pardon
et il a des moments glorieux il a fondé
le Havre donc on lui pardonne tout mais
non sont deux figures je vais très vite
pardon ce sont deux figures qui qui
existent par l'idée de fondation et par
l'idée de réconciliation
la fondation d'un état François 1er et
Henri IV sont pénétrés de l'idée qu'il
faut créer une forme d'État qui va
devenir l'État moderne
la fondation par la culture c'est l'édit
de Villers-Cotterêts dont aujourd'hui on
retient simplement l'article qui
explique qu'on va écrire tout en
français enfin qui dit plein d'autres
choses et pas toutes glorieuses pas
toutes glorieuses mais enfin qui dit ça
le Collège de France c'est à dire l'idée
que le savoir
et la connaissance ne doivent pas être
réservés
à la Sorbonne et à l'université
c'est incroyable et la ville du hard
mais je dis je peux pas l'oublier qui
est une idée d'une incroyable modernité
me semble-t-il donc la fondation et puis
Henri IV c'est la réconciliation et
comme vous allez tous vous jeter sur le
livre qui est d'ailleurs épuisé François
en tout cas moi j'ai pas réussi à
l'acheter j'ai dû l'emprunter dans une
bibliothèque heureusement bien
achalandée au Havre
vous y trouverez un chapitre qui
s'appelle l'art de gouverner et vous
voyez que Henri IV confronté à des
difficultés considérables ce qui laisse
d'ailleurs permet de mettre un peu de
distance entre ce qu'on vit parce qu'il
y a d'autres moments dans l'histoire de
France où il y a eu des difficultés
considérables j'ai quand même réappris
pour tout dire en fait un peu appris que
l'excellent Henri IV avait dans un
moment de grande difficulté conçu l'idée
d'une forme de de grand débat
mais c'est vrai deux grands débats dont
il a d'ailleurs pas suivi tous les
enseignements sur le conseil de Sully
j'ai découvert les agacements profonds
d'Henri IV face au Parlement qui était à
l'époque plutôt la justice que que le
système parlementaire profond je l'ai
découvert incroyablement attaché au bon
état des finances publiques lui-même
disant et franchement ça devrait nous
faire réfléchir qu'il ne pouvait pas y
avoir de réconciliation en français sans
finance publique tenue
c'est
enfin ça fait réfléchir parce que c'est
écrit il y a longtemps mais ça reste à
mon avis extrêmement vrai et puis la
dernière chose puisque j'étais à
Fontainebleau avec Jean-Paul puis à la
naissance de renaissance et que
maintenant je suis avec François
l'édit de Nantes c'est-à-dire au fond un
texte qui d'une certaine façon pourrait
avoir valeur constitutionnelle l'idée
que on organise par le droit une forme
de liberté et notamment de liberté
religieuse ce qui est totalement nouveau
dans le monde de l'époque qui me paraît
pas complètement là non plus dépassée
voir déplacer et qui sera abrogé en 1685
à Fontainebleau par Louis XIV bref
dans le moment où nous vivons dans le
moment où Renaissance secret dans le
moment où nous sommes confrontés à de
telles difficultés je pense que notre
objectif celui qui nous réunit celui sur
lequel nous pouvons partager celui sur
lequel nous pouvons construire c'est au
fond l'objectif même de ces deux
souverains de la Renaissance fondé la
nouvelle puissance française
et réconcilier les Français la puissance
c'est pas quelque chose d'hégémonique
c'est quelque chose qui sert à faire
prévaloir ses intérêts et être à la
hauteur face aux enjeux du monde
fonder et refonder les éléments de la
puissance française et réconcilier les
Françaises et les Français avec
eux-mêmes d'une certaine façon et d'une
certaine façon peut-être aussi avec la
France c'est ce que je nous souhaite
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
je ne ferai pas de discours
demain peut-être si vous revenez et vous
reviendrez tous et j'espère d'autres
encore qui nous ont pas encore rejoint
mais j'étais très heureux de ce moment
de rencontre et de franchise avec le
sourire
avec profondeur y compris profondeur
historique
et d'ailleurs
Henri
IV et François 1er
François 1er est le grand oncle d'Henri
IV
c'est le frère de sa grand-mère
et donc ça prouve qu'entre le Havre
qui sont les deux lieux de naissance de
ses souverains
il y a quelque chose de au fond de de
sympathique faut ajouter capot à notre
souverain est né qui s'appelle
Bernadotte
qui a été roi de Suède
et dont les descendants sont encore sur
le trône
ce qui veut dire que l'adhésion récente
de la Suède aux préoccupations qui sont
les nôtres pour des raisons militaires
nous donne à penser aussi sur la
difficulté des temps les Suédois étaient
venus chercher
Bernadotte parce qu'il venait de subir
une immense défaite devant la Russie
alors ils ont cherché quelqu'un qui
savait faire la guerre
ils sont venus à Pau merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]